i think they definitely want to see what
life would be like with a baby kim
kardashian is rooting for a little baby
kravis
yep the 41 year old skims founder
stopped by ellen on wednesday to talk
about her famous family's new hulu
series the kardashians
over the last year
we've seen such transformations from all
of us
you have a real insight into what the
girls are doing not only what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
and kim she opens up about her sister
courtney and her fiance travis barkers
plans to have a baby of their own you'll
see their their journey and um
it's really i think when you find love
that you know you can't live without and
there's still a chance she's in her
early 40s i think they definitely want
to see what life would be like with a
baby and they share their whole story
and have been super open and i think
people really want to see like how cute
they are and how
much they make out in a trailer for the
new show fans caught a glimpse of the 42
year old pooch founder and the 46 year
old blink 182 drummer at the doctor's
office
travis and i want to have a baby
put the sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio what has it been like to be on the
path to baby with travis i mean it's a
beautiful thing that we'd love to have
happen um but
you know the journey is a bit hard for
any women who have been on it and
emotional
courtney and travis got engaged in
october and earlier this month they said
i do in an unofficial las vegas ceremony
you did a practice run on the wedding
congratulations thank you so
when is the real wedding we don't know
yet we're just you know living our best
lives
of course courtney shares three kids
with her ex scott disick 12 year old
mason nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign while travis has
two kids with his ex shayna mookler 18
year old landon and 16 year old alabama
our children come first and their
happiness and as long as you know the
kardashians are good to my kids you know
that's all that matters to me as a mom
back in february a source told et that
court and trav are so in love and are
open to the idea of having children
together and growing their family and
last month e.t source explained that the
idea of having a child is very important
and exciting to them adding that their
family is very supportive of the idea
oh we all love it this is her time to
shine baby
[Music]
you